I needed that ladies and gentlemen I've
had so many shitty weeks but this is a
shitty week I'm telling you no really
the one bright spot I can find is that
Trump finally found some white people to
fight with Denmark he's fighting with
Denmark because you know this he's been
wanting to buy Greenland by the way
today Puerto Rico said you don't take
care of the islands you already have
but as I've said it's not a crazy idea
to want to own Greenland other
presidents have suggested it but they
took no for an answer
the Prime Minister told him not for sale
and he said that's what milania's parent
said the prime minister of Denmark nasty
woman said his offer was absurd and
Trump said you nasty and you've insulted
America do you wanted to talk to the
manager he is off his rocker he's giving
hour-long press conferences on the White
House lawn
brought to you by adderall the President
of the United States stands in the
driveway every day and screams had
people I mean I know a lot of old guys
are like get off my Lord he's like get
on my walk
the suit saves it it's all about the
suit really he wasn't wearing this suit
ordinarily people who do that are
wearing a bathrobe with the garden hose
in them the precedent is the inflatable
arm-flailing tube-man outside of the car
dealership that's who he is I don't want
to say he has the mind of a child
but today Jeffery Epstein's ghost tried
to [ __ ] it
gentle good humor that's what we do very
gentle now do you see now why I say we
need a recession I know it's gonna be
painful but we have to get rid of this
guy and recession Trump now says not to
worry
he says the economy's going
fantastically and other than always when
is he ever lied yeah he says not to
worry about a recession he says he
always finds a way to win and that he
wrote the book on surviving financial
catastrophe specifically chapter 11 this
is a bad sign today a Greenland offered
to buy us a now some some funeral news
to report yesterday David Koch of the
zillionaire Koch brothers died plays of
prostate cancer I guess I'm going to
have to reevaluate my low opinion of
prostate cancer he was he was 79 but his
family says they wish it could be longer
but at least he lived long enough to see
the Amazon catch fire
condolences poured in from all the
politicians he owned and mourners are
being asked in lieu of flowers to just
leave their car engine running
as for his remains he is asked to be
cremated and have his ashes blown into a
child's lungs now I know these seem like
harsh words and harsh jokes and I'm sure
I will be condemned for them on Fox News
which will portray mr. Koch as a
principled libertarian who believe in
the free market he and his brother have
done more than anybody to fund climate
science deniers for decades oh [ __ ] him
the Amazon is burning up I'm glad he's
dead
[Applause]
you